- One thing that came out
on my podcast with him,
'cause I asked him,
there's this misconception
that old people or
people that are poor
lost money at my firm.
It just wasn't true,
it was not true.
I ran the firm and this
was a policy in place
we only call rich people.
Now it's A, was on purpose,
'cause I didn't want people
that couldn't afford
to lose, to lose
But also 'cause I'm
a greedy bastard.
Like, "Hey, you know what?
"If you're gonna go take money,
"might as well take it from
those who have the most
"'cause you're
gonna get the most."
So I'm not trying to say I
was the greatest guy ever,
but I certainly
purposely steered clear
of people that could not
afford to lose money, right?
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin, and joining
me today is an entrepreneur,
a motivational speaker,
a best-selling author,
and the original Wolf of
Wall Street, Jordan Belfort.
Finally, welcome to
"The Rubin Report".
- How are ya? Glad to be here.
What's going on?
- I'm good.
(laughs)
Well, I thought you'd
be a perfect guy to
have on this week,
because we are both in this
crazy town of Los Angeles.
I've been to your house.
It ain't bad, my friend.
You're in your beautiful studio
and you've got a
pretty swank set up.
But tomorrow, Gavin
Newsom is gonna allow us
to leave our homes.
Can you believe it's
actually happening?
- Let me give you my take on it.
I don't think anybody
really listened to him.
I don't think there
was any lockdown
that I noticed other
than I feel terrible
for restaurant owners
who were forced for no good
reason, at least in my opinion,
to close their outdoor dining
after they spent tons of money
putting in the safeguards
that one would need to
have outdoor dining,
and all the barriers,
partitions, heaters,
I mean, it's crazy.
And then just to...
I mean, I really feel bad.
But I have to say,
other than that,
I think there was corona
fatigue here in LA,
and it was more of a
ceremonial lockdown.
I remember the first
lockdown, Dave,
there was no one on the street,
there was no cars around.
This was no that over
the last four weeks.
It was like, "Oh, let's screw
over all the restaurant owners
"and just wipe 'em
outta business."
That's kinda what
it felt like to me.
How 'bout you?
- Yeah, I mean, I think...
Well, my audience knows,
we've basically been
ignoring it around here,
and I feel bad for the
small business owners
and the restaurateurs.
And it's sad when I'm
in your neighborhood
or even in my neighborhood
where you drive by the main
drags and everything's closed.
But that's kind of a good
spot for us to start,
because for the
people that know you,
they know the Leo
DiCaprio version of you.
But in a way, you're
kind of a startup guy.
You're gritty,
and you get out there
and you do stuff,
that's what your whole career,
the ups and the
downs has been about.
If you right now were just
trying to start up something,
how would you feel in
the midst of knowing
that the government
can just come in
and shut you down at any point?
- I feel like at this point,
you have to take advantage
of that insane fact
that the government can come in
and shut down many different
types of commerce right now.
So what you wanna do
is position yourself
in an industry or business
that would give you
the greatest likelihood
of being insulated from
any of those shutdowns.
So things that are
delivered online
and can be done from the home,
and get delivered
through the mail.
Those are the sort
of things right now
that everyone is focusing on.
Things that are...
Virtualizing,
basically everything.
So I think it is...
I hate to say this, but it's
true in the worst of times,
you typically have
the most opportunity.
The people who are willing to
go out there and take risks.
So like if I look
at my business,
and I had this conversation
with someone just last night
about that there's a new
round of PPP loans coming out
and I apply for it, and
I deserve to get it.
My business got
decimated, decimated,
my speaking business, 'cause
that was my core business.
But now I'm doing well
'cause I have a new business.
But the point is what business
were in the last year,
you have to say, "Okay..."
Well, in the new reality,
the new normal if you wanna
call it, those rules...
You can't just go out there
and do business the
way you used to do it.
I have people
working in my house.
I don't have an office.
I focus on online delivery,
on virtual learning,
on other things I know
that won't be as impacted.
So I think that you have
to go out there right now
and assume that at
any given moment,
the rug can be pulled
out from under your feet.
And while we were growing
up, we used to go like,
"Oh, let's go into defensive
industries like food,
"and everyone needs to eat like
the movies, everyone goes."
Those were defensive
industries, right?
Well, now, defensive
industries are characterized
as things that are defensive
that can't be shut down
by draconian state
and government
measures, it's insane.
- So do you think
that's kinda the key
to being a good business person,
a good business guy in general,
someone who can just see
that things have changed?
Like I think a lot
of people right now,
they still think that the
old world's coming back.
They still think February
2020 is coming back.
But February 2021 is
gonna be way different
than February 2020
and I don't think
February 2020 comes back.
- I think there's one thing
that's always constant
in this world,
and that is that the
world's always changing.
The difference right now, and
I think you're 100% right,
I don't think things
are going back
to the way they were, ever.
I really don't.
And not that people
won't have...
I think people will
not always wear masks,
and I think there won't always
be people social distancing.
'Cause if you look
back right now,
we're in the middle of bubbles
with things like Bitcoin
and all this crazy
stuff going on,
with real estate prices
soaring in certain areas.
And you look back in 2008
and we didn't learn anything.
It's the same thing
again, another bubble.
So people like...
It was really bad after 2008.
In 2008 it was like, "Oh,
we gotta be really careful.
"We can't have bubbles."
And people forget
really quickly.
But I think you're
right though that...
I think there's a new way
that people have
become accustomed to
consuming everything,
whether it's food, movies,
learning, buying products.
I think that people have
gotten comfortable right now,
or used to and even
prefer in some respects
to buy things and stay home.
And I think that's
never gonna change.
I think that's gonna
be here to stay.
There's a movie, some
crazy movie that was out.
I think Bruce Willis was
in this movie where they...
What was it called?
Where they all
lived virtual lives,
they're actually locked
away in these little shells,
they have their counterparts,
their clones go out there
and move through the world
because it's too
dangerous and too deadly
with viruses and diseases.
It's a real interesting movie,
but it's almost like where
we're heading towards,
I feel like.
- Yeah, I'm shocked I
don't know what that is.
But it's got a bit
of "The Matrix" in
there for sure, right?
Like we're just-
- 100%.
- We're just the batteries
for the digital
world, in essence.
- Basically, yeah.
I think that one of the
things you brought up
was a very good point
is that, what makes a
great business person?
It's not just seeing,
it's also the ability
to pivot quickly.
It's pivoting and learning
how to be wrong quickly too.
You have to learn how to
try things and be wrong
and live to fight another day.
Not to get so
emotionally involved
in the things that you're trying
where you feel like,
"I gotta make it work,
"'cause I went this far."
No, maybe it was
just a bad idea,
and you try it,
doesn't work, next.
And really need to not get
caught up in bad ideas,
not to go down rabbit holes,
and also just to keep
trying, and trying,
and trying it again until
you find that model.
And I think if you
do that right now,
there is a path to success
for everybody out there,
no matter how desperate
things might seem right now.
- So that right there
is what I wanna spend most
of our time talking about,
because that's your expertise.
And it's not something
you're just talking about.
You've frickin' lived it.
- Right, I lived it.
Again and again, always, yeah.
- (laughs) But one thing
before we get to that,
since we are both
in LA right now,
my audience knows.
I went to Florida
a couple weeks ago,
I was happy, man, it
was open and good,
people were smiling,
there was some great energy
there and everything else.
Are you worried about
the future of LA,
not only 'cause of Newsom,
and lockdowns, and all that,
but the progressive
Mayor Garcetti here,
and just generally the amount
of homeless, and drugs,
and the whole frickin' thing?
- Yeah, I'm outta here.
I'm getting outta here.
- Oh, you are? Oh, great.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You're on my short list of
like four friends left now.
- I gotta go.
I might keep a small
apartment here at some point.
Listen, California was the place
that everybody else
dreamed of moving to.
And the weather is beautiful,
the terrain is beautiful,
the air is mostly clear,
at least where we are.
But I think really
poor political policies
have turned it into
a frickin' cesspool.
Not only that, into
a high-tax cesspool.
I'm okay to pay taxes
if they're gonna use those
taxes for great things.
But they're not.
They use the taxes,
they're wasted.
And it's honestly beyond the
pale what's happening here.
And I think the only
solace I can think
is I think it's worse
in San Francisco.
So I think it's
actually worse there.
Well, it's not as bad there yet.
So I plan on moving to Florida.
But what's bothering me is it's
causing a bubble right now.
Everyone's running to Florida,
driving up the
real estate prices,
I'm kinda waiting like,
"Hmm, I don't know."
But again, it's this
weird thing here
where you and I are watching,
we're almost sitting here
and watching it in real time,
the decline and unraveling
of a once great city.
It's insane to watch.
- Yeah, and what's
also weird about it,
and I think this exact
same thing happened
in San Francisco was it
doesn't happen overnight,
it takes a couple years.
But if you talk to
literally everybody,
anyone that will talk to you,
they all admit it's goin
in the wrong direction,
yet for some reason,
people in LA,
they can't make the connection
between voting for policies
and these politicians,
and then the bad
stuff that happens.
There's a complete
disconnect there.
- Because I think what
happens is that...
And I don't wanna get
to left-right here.
I think that what the democrats
have been very, very clever
and very adept at this
hearts and minds campaign
of using this sort of...
They've linked these things
where there's some
moral high ground
that they have with
things like climate,
and gay rights, and other things
that are completely
unlinked to the economy,
and yet it becomes
an emotional issue.
And people, when they
go to the voting booth,
often vote based on emotion
and not based on logic.
And they've been
really, really clever.
They've consolidated this party,
which comes to represent things
that I think most people
don't agree with fiscally.
But they have this overwhelming,
and I think the Republicans
have made some huge errors,
like gay rights.
I mean, good lord! Stop already!
Will you just stop?
Just accept it. It's so stupid.
So if the Republicans
hopefully will wake up
and see what's
going on right now.
And they've come a
long way, I believe.
I don't wanna get caught up
in the election and stuff,
but I think that it's time
for the Republican party
to be what it should be,
which is the most inclusive
party for everybody
that cares about
less government,
more rights for people,
and not screwing around
with everybody's life.
And both cars
always get hijacked
by the extremists
on either side.
But what happens is the
extremists on the left
have this moral high
ground, so to speak,
and they're using that to
win the hearts and minds
of young people,
and the academics,
and the high-tech mafia there,
whatever you wanna call it,
and it's causing elections
to be swayed in one way
and it's basically taking
this once great city
and it's essentially flushing
it, literally, down the drain.
- Alright, well, look,
if you buy a couple
acres in Florida,
maybe just clear out some
land for me and I'll slowly--
- Yeah, by the gator patch.
Like, "Hey, Dave, come on.
"Don't worry, they don't bite.
"They're not crocs,
they're alligators."
Big difference.
(laughs)
- Yeah, big difference,
big difference.
Alright, so let's talk about
that other stuff, though.
Let's talk about the
stuff that you really...
It's your area of expertise.
First off, I am sure that
everyone watching this
has seen "Wolf of Wall Street".
But for the people that aren't
sure who Jordan Belfort is,
give me the minute elevator
pitch on what you've done.
- So when I was very young...
We grew up in Long
Island, both of us, right?
- Yeah.
- I started a firm
in the late '80s and I uncovered
this niche in the market
for selling $5 stocks to
the richest Americans.
No one had tried it before.
And I then, very
shortly thereafter
discovered a way of
training sales people
so I could take average people
that really weren't
great at sales
and make them
unbelievable at sales.
Those two things
combined resulted
in me building what
became very quickly,
the largest firm in the country
back when I was still
in my early to mid-20s,
and I was making a
million bucks a week,
and I was from a poor family,
and I absolutely went hog wild
and lived out every
adolescent fantasy
I could ever have dreamed of,
from buying a white
Ferrari Testarossa
'cause Don Johnson had
one in "Miami Vice",
from taking a
private jet out to LA
and renting out the
presidential suite
in the Beverly Wilshire
'cause Richard Gere had
done it in "Pretty Woman".
I went full on there.
And ultimately it started off
as a beautiful, amazing thing.
And I lost my way, and I started
manipulating some stocks,
smuggled money to Switzerland,
clients lost money,
I went to jail,
and I wrote a book about it,
and that book became a movie.
And I got really lucky
'cause the thing is
when you make a movie there's
two things can happen.
You could have a
movie made about you,
and I love Danny DeVito,
but let's just say,
you could get played
by Danny DeVito or--
- (laughs) No
offense, no offense.
- I love Danny, but,
or Leonardo DiCaprio
and have Martin Scorsese
direct that movie.
And I have to say, what
they did is they took a book
that I worked very hard
on and I was proud of,
and the writer, Terrance
Winters, a brilliant guy,
and all of us together
created what really
ended up being
a very special, amazing movie
that has certainly
stood the test of time
and become probably one
of the biggest cult hits
of all time.
And I think it will...
And I don't see it ending,
I think it's just
here to stay forever,
'cause it really
connects with people.
Yeah and it's awesome. (laughs)
Scorsese, what could
you say, right? (laughs)
- It's just perfect.
I mean, the movie, really,
from start to finish
is just perfect.
The speech that
Leo, that you give,
I mean, is just absolutely epic
and has been memed into
a million other things.
- I know. (laughs)
- But you mentioned
that we're both
from Long Island.
You were born in '62, right?
Am I allowed to say that?
- Correct. Yeah, sure.
- Am I allowed to say that?
- Absolutely.
- You got four-
- I look pretty good
considering all the drugs
I've consumed, right?
I mean, good lord,
I should be like Keith Richards
from the Rolling Stones.
But thank God, I did
pretty well, yeah?
- No, no, I can't see
through your skin.
You're doing all right.
But no, you got 14 years on me,
but we basically come from
virtually the same town.
And a lot of guys
that are in the movie
that you train, in effect,
are from Syosset,
they're from Plainview,
it's a lot of these
local Long Island towns
right outside New York City.
And we talked about this
when I was on your show,
but I'm sorta fascinated by it.
There is something
about Long Island
that has generated so
many talented people,
corrupt people, comedians,
actors, money guys.
- Dave.
- It's nuts.
- I was gonna say, I
didn't wanna interrupt you.
I was like, "There's
something in the water."
- There's something
in the water.
- Like my mother used
to always to say, "There's
something in the water."
Like even in my apartment
building, on my floor,
I lived in this six-story,
low-rent apartment building.
Three people on my floor
went out to Wall Street
and built massive firms.
Now, one of them,
besides he was a good
friend, so he worked,
but another was an independent
guy named Randy Pace
who I babysat for his kids.
He's 10 years passed away now.
He had one of the largest firms
on Wall Street in the '70s.
So it's like there's
something, and Syosset,
it's like the
Syosset Jericho thing
and I was like bay side.
And I'll tell you
what I think it is.
I'll tell you what
I think it is.
I think it is a combination of
proximity to massive wealth,
but not actually
having massive wealth.
It's about not being so poor
that it seems out of reach,
it's about having
a great education,
so it creates this
almost aspiration,
like you almost feel
like it's just there,
it's within your reach,
you see it, it's not yours,
you're given the tools.
Because I think what's
really sad sometimes
kids that grow up
in these bad areas,
they have the deck
stacked against them
like they don't have
a great education,
they have a lot
of gang violence.
It's almost like they
have to really be special
to make it out.
And that, hopefully,
will continue to
change and get better.
But I think we didn't have that.
Although I wasn't born rich,
something bad had to happen
for me not to get out
to the next level.
It was such a pathway out
and I think part of it
is that stressing
education, for sure,
was just a big thing in my area.
And also, there was
this mythical thing
like you move out to Long
Island, you get rich.
That was a path.
And I think that's part of it.
I think that if you
take those things
and it creates a sort
of competition and
pathway to success.
That's my opinion.
- So when you were
building the companies
and you figured out
how you could do this
by sort of reaching the
rich people with something
that wasn't normally thought
of as kind of in their world,
what kinda like ethical
issues were you having
as you were doing it?
Like at first did you
think it was fully legit
and then kinda lost control,
or did you kinda know,
or did you not know,
or what were you
struggling with?
- Very good question.
So number one,
there's two things.
There was a very
interesting fact
that came out on my podcast.
I had the FBI agent
who indicted me,
he's a friend of mine
now, wonderful guy.
- Oh, man, alright,
I gotta listen to that.
- The guy who put me in jail.
Yeah, you should have him on
your podcast, he's a great guy.
- Yeah.
- And one thing that came out
on my podcast with him
'cause I asked him,
there's this misconception
that old people
or people that are poor
lost money at my firm.
And it just wasn't
true. It was not true.
I ran the firm and there
was a policy in place,
we only call rich people.
Now, A, it was purpose,
'cause I didn't want people
that couldn't afford
to lose to lose.
But also, 'cause I'm
a greedy bastard.
Like, "Hey, if you're
gonna go take money,
"might as well go take it
from those who have the most
"'cause you're
gonna get the most."
So I'm not trying to say I
was the greatest guy ever,
but I certainly
purposely steering clear
of people that could not
afford to lose money, right?
But yet the perception
was that people that
couldn't afford lost money.
The FBI agent clarified,
'cause what happened
was I left the firm,
I sold the firm in '95.
And after that...
And before that it
was very controlled
and we were basically...
It wasn't stealing.
It started off perfectly legit,
and then it started to
spiral out of control,
but it was very contained,
about 95% legit.
I would say now, that given
what I see on Wall Street,
what I did was 100% legitimate.
Now, given what I see
happening every single day,
I used to always say I
deserved to go to jail,
now I don't really
think so anymore,
'cause there's such
corruption on Wall Street,
it's so bad now.
I say, well, okay, well
I did things wrong,
but it's not nearly...
I didn't bankrupt Greece
or Iceland at least,
so I'm not that
bad a guy, right?
Seriously, the things
that you see now happening
in the bigger firms
is unbelievable.
But the big mistake I made
was this lapse of ethics
one step at a time.
So I wanna be clear,
I did break the law.
I did deserve to go to
jail for breaking the law.
Though my perspectives changes
what I see comparatively,
but still, I don't wanna say...
I did break the law.
It started off
perfectly legitimate
trying to make people money
and then I made some
fundamental errors
and I allowed the
firm to grow too fast
and I lost control of it.
And then, the first time
I really broke the law,
I was like, "Oh, I'll do it
once, I'll never do it again."
But then my line of
morality got moved a bit.
So next time, you do
things good again,
and then next time
you step over,
it's a little bit further to
the right and then back in.
Before you know it,
through these tiny, almost
imperceptible steps,
you're doing things you
thought you'd never do,
you're associating
with people you never
thought you'd associate with
and it all seems perfectly okay.
It's like you dip your toe
into a bathtub piping hot water
and go, "Oh, wow, so hot!"
And then three minutes
later, you're in the water
and it feels fine.
Now, when I was a young boy, I
remember distinctly thinking,
"Oh, I know what's going on.
"I get in the bath and I'm
the water's cooling down
"because my body's cool,"
but no the water's
not cooling down,
you're just getting used to it.
And that was the mistake I made.
And it's a mistake I'm
very aware of today.
I won't even take one little
step over the ethical line,
like I am real...
I am more careful
than anybody else
because I can't afford to
have a second hiccup here.
So I always say to myself,
"Any action I take,
"if it's even the
slightest bit unethical,
"I just won't do it.
"I'm not gonna
take that chance."
That's my best protection
against ever doing
anything wrong again.
And I think it's really good
for everyone to look that way.
But there are some things in
life where there's gray areas,
and there's nothing wrong
with playing in the gray.
You know what I'm saying?
But you know, I
think that the test
is if you're going to hurt
someone else along the way,
that's probably the
single thing that...
That's like, eh, if you're
gonna hurt someone else.
If it's a victim
list in the gray,
okay, well, you
could consider it.
But other than
that, it's a no go.
- Well, I just love
the honesty there.
Because I think a lot of
people think it's like,
oh, they are good
people and then one day,
they just make a decision
to do bad things,
where it's like oh, along
the way of building something
that started just
exploding under you
like some strange
decision not strange,
some decisions start being made,
and then next thing you know,
you're in that different water.
But one of the things...
I watched the movie
about two weeks ago
in preparation for this
and I've seen it probably
10 times already.
But one of the things that I
think is your greatest skill,
and I sense probably what
you get the most joy from
is the way you were able
to train these guys,
just guys that weren't thinking
that they were gonna
be selling stocks,
guys that probably didn't
have much of a future,
guys that were (laughs)
doing all kinds of drugs
and had all kinds
of other problems.
But that you could turn them
into something that they
weren't is pretty cool.
- It still might to this day,
it's definitely
the passion I have.
And I love the fact that I
go out and get to do that
not as much now with COVID
but I still do it virtually
and I'm sure that part
will eventually come back.
I'm speaking to live in these
huge stadiums and stuff,
which I used to do a lot of.
What I really think and
I noticed this very young
when I was in my early
20s and I had this ability
to kinda motivate
and just naturally knew
what someone wanted to hear
and I really perfected
that over many, many years.
But I think the most
important thing to take away
to everyone listening
is that I don't think
that you the listener,
I don't know who you all are,
but what you're truly capable of
and I think people
tend to not realize
what they're truly capable of.
We all have all this
really bad programming.
And so much of it comes down
to you not possessing
the skills that you need.
There are certain core skills
that you need to
succeed in this world.
And they're not all
taught, most aren't taught.
Many of us are naturally
good at certain things.
What we don't realize is
that, like for example,
you wanna play tennis and
you suck, so what do you do?
You take tennis lessons, and
you go and get lessons, right?
You know, well, if
you wanna go out
and succeed in the
world of business
and make money, what do you do?
Get lessons like it's just so...
People fail to make
this connection
that all of these
things, especially now,
where every bit of information
is so at your fingertips,
pretty much everything that
you need can be learned
or can be found.
And if you're struggling
right now making money
or finding a career
or just feeling like you're
living an empowered life,
it's not because you are
fundamentally flawed or inferior
or not worth it,
it's because you probably
lack some specific knowledge
that you need to have in
order to realize your dreams
and your hopes,
and all the things
that would just make you feel
like life is just awesome.
And it's all out there.
And I think it's so fricking
sad that people are like...
They get blocked
from going out there
and living the life they deserve
because they lack knowledge.
It's knowledge and
that's the thing.
It's not, yeah, there's talent,
I'm never going to be Roger
Federer on the tennis court,
but I could get good
enough to have a lot of fun
and win a lot of games
from some good plays.
You're never gonna be
me as a salesperson,
but I could teach you
to be so good at it now
that you'll get whatever
you want in life.
And it's not just sales,
it could be how do you run a
business, it's all out there,
the templates, the work
has been done by people.
Granted, it's the promise a
lot of charlatans out there
teaching stuff as well,
but you could kind of...
You could look at reviews
and search around,
but I would urge everybody here,
I don't care, if time
to talk right now
or you feel like you don't
know which way to turn,
you have the ability to do
whatever you want, you just do
as long as you're
willing to take the time
to learn the things you have
to learn and take some risks.
- Yeah, and now you can learn
so much of it for free, too.
It's like YouTube.
A lot of this stuff is free.
- It's free.
- Yeah, I mean, I know people
are paying you a lot of money
to go to your seminars,
but at the same time...
- People pay me every single
day and they buy my courses.
And you know what you
can you can go online,
go to my own website,
and get enough for free.
The difference is that
of course, if you pay,
it's all perfectly
laid out for you.
It's the next level,
but I purposely give...
I want people...
If you can't afford it,
just go and get the
stuff for free from me.
Because once they
do, they'll buy
'cause they'll see,
"Oh, wow, it's great.
"But I'd rather have
it all laid out for me
"in exactly the right order."
And it's a better deal for them.
But you can get everything
for free so it's not money.
And everyone has enough
time when it comes down.
So what happens is people,
they get caught up in
these limiting beliefs
with self defeating
attitudes and negative pro
and they start thinking that,
"This is my lot in
life, and I'm stuck.
"And maybe it works for
this guy or that guy
"or Jordan or Dave
but I'm not them."
And it's so sad.
I think now, if there's
ever been a time
where you can reinvent
yourself, now is the time.
The whole world is like...
The whole world is going online.
Everyone is in that same
boat of what's next?
There's money always to be
made in those situations?
- Yeah, I totally agree.
It's like we're watching
the old world go away.
But there is a new
world on the horizon.
And there's gonna
be a lot of people
that build a lot of cool stuff
and make a lot of
money in that process.
- Last night, a friend
of mine had some surgery,
and I was at his house and
he's telling me about Bitcoin
and GameStop and
all these things.
And I was really ragging
on this new world
of a lot of some of the way
money is being made right now.
But I think he
missed my message.
My point is that I don't play
myself in some of these things
that I think it could
go one way or the other.
I'm more of a
skills based player
like I just like things
that are more skills based
so I could stack
the deck in my favor
by being really
great at something
versus when I look
at throwing a dart
and hoping I catch it
going up versus going down.
So my friend's like,
"Oh you so negative
on the new world."
And I agree, I'm
not, I'm positive,
I think that you're 100% right.
The old world as we knew it,
is basically either, I
wouldn't say it's dead,
but it's dying, a
very rapid death.
And there's this new entity
forming right before our eyes
of how people go about
and consume and do and live
everything and everywhere.
And opportunity is all
around us right now.
And as long as you're willing
to accept the fact
that you're right,
that it's not gonna
be February 2020
in another month right
now, it's going to be 2021.
And the lock downs
will end eventually.
And you know what there
will be opportunity,
I believe that's gonna
be extraordinary,
there's also gonna
be some hell to pay
for all the fiscal
irresponsibility,
but that's a separate issue.
- Yeah, so this is an odd
segue from the success part.
But as you were doing
all of this stuff,
and the money and the traveling
and all the crazy
stuff you're doing,
you were on a lot of drugs.
I mean, the movie is sort of
an adventure through drugs.
In retrospect, are you shocked
that you were even
able to survive
and there were some moments
where maybe you wouldn't have.
- Shocked at this point,
I think it's an
amazing testament
to the resilience
of the human body,
like for the human liver
One thing I had going for me
is I wasn't a big drinker.
And I think that what happens
with a lot of the
drugs that I took,
and I got plain lucky.
Better men than may
have taken one hot dose
and they've died
like Heath Ledger and a
lot of great people, right?
I got lucky, no doubt about it.
But I wasn't a drinker.
And I think what
happens with alcohol
is that it sort of
takes a different...
It takes drugs
that you might know
what the safe doses are for you
and it throws it out the window.
It intensifies the
effect of lots of drugs
and it depresses breathing
and your heart beat.
And I think I was pretty
at least aware enough
that I never got myself...
I mean, I overdosed once.
But that was pretty
much on purpose.
It was more of an
out cry of an act
more than trying to kill myself.
But I mean, I think
I got very lucky
'cause at the end of the day,
I look at many people who
I went through that with.
They never really
recovered fully.
They never really...
If they're around,
they look unhealthy.
Some of them died.
And also by the grace of
God, by the way, as well.
I mean, I gotta say I think
that I've never been...
I believe in God but I
think that at this point,
certainly, there's
definitely a path to me
that wasn't supposed
to end back then.
And I've been sober
for a really long time.
I'd still drink a little bit,
but I haven't done drugs.
It's been a very, very...
The last time I really partied
hard was April 17th 1997.
That was my date when I
went to AA and that was it.
And then I've dabbled a
couple of times since then.
But never, I've
never done drugs,
anything more than a little bit.
I tried smoking pot a
few times, but that's it.
- (laughs) Yeah, but a
lot of the guys though,
they either didn't make it
are they're pretty banged up.
- Yeah, it's pretty terrible.
But I think also my drug
choice was mostly like...
It was Quaaludes and
cocaine, it wasn't heroin.
And heroin is more
of like the deathblow
'cause it depresses
your breathing,
choking on your own
vomit, stuff like that.
I think the drugs that I
did were more, not safer,
like (laughs)
they're safe drugs,
but I think they're
less bad, so to speak.
Like on the terrible index
and not quite as terrible.
- (laughs) Right, exactly.
Alright, that's good
to know, though,
that you do still drink--
- For all you children
out there...
(laughs)
- Yeah, you do still drink
occasionally, though.
- Yeah, I love a nice little
glass of wine here and there.
I've never drank I
never drink enough
to get really drunk though ever.
It's just not my thing.
Yeah, so what right now are you
seeing sort of business wise
with all the chaos said
with the dinner that you had
with your friend last night,
and everyone's sort of
hot on Bitcoin right now.
And there's suddenly
a whole bunch
of social media alternatives.
I think you know a little bit
about what I'm doing
with locals.com.
There's a whole bunch of
stuff sort of appearing.
Are there things that are really
interesting you right now?
- Yeah, so I have
my own business,
which is doing really well,
I'm growing it right now,
which is recruiting business
that I'm rolling out
around the world right now
where I help companies scale
by finding them salespeople.
So, that's my long term
outcome that I see.
I think a lot of the things
like these Bitcoin and train...
Listen, there's windows of
opportunity for everything.
What always scares
me about Bitcoin
is that as much as I know
about the government,
and how they detest
money laundering,
I just scratched
my head and say,
"How would they allow
this to become something
"that could so easily be
used to launder money."
And it can I don't care what...
Listen, I have a lot of friends
that are really successful
that love Bitcoin and I
have some that hate Bitcoin.
And the ones that love Bitcoin,
they're legitimate people
and they're not scamming.
They're just like they like it,
they have their reasons why.
But it's just I
know enough about it
it's very easy to use Bitcoin
to hide money and do deals
that would otherwise be
much more difficult to do
through the traditional
banking system.
So my point is
I'm not saying that's what
Bitcoin it's only used for,
'cause it's not.
But why would the government...
It's my fear is that
the government's saying,
"We spent all this time trying
to stamp out Switzerland,
"and the Caymans.
"So alright, well, great,
"let's just get darn
control over now,
"to a system that
we can't control."
It doesn't make sense to me.
The only one that
does make sense to me
is if it's the government
itself that released Bitcoin,
and they know everything.
It was actually the
CIA or the government
that's behind the whole
thing and they're like,
"Yeah go hide your
money, it's great."
And like they know
where everything is.
If that came out and I'd say,
"Uh huh , now it
all makes sense."
- Now you're now you're really
going down the rabbit hole.
- But other than that,
I think the technology
itself of blockchain
is really elegant, I think
it's got a lot of uses.
And I think that...
I understand that Bitcoin has
a lot of people that like it,
and the more people, there's
a network effect on that
in terms of not so
much for spending it
but there's a network
effect of the more people
that think it's worth something,
I guess it really
is in some respect.
And then also that we
always look at things
in the purview of
the United States
and its having a
stable currency.
So imagine if
you're in a country
or let's say you're in
Peru, or somewhere or Chile,
or in that country, and the
currency is devaluing or Cuba,
as it's almost impossible
to be able to hold currency
because it's not worth it,
they will usually use dollars.
But Bitcoin I guess,
is an alternative.
It's not very good
for transactions.
It's a store house of value,
I guess it's much better
than their own basically
worthless currency.
So I think there's applications
for other countries
that we probably
don't realize is much
coming from the United States.
I've seen it as I
go around the world,
that people in other countries,
they're much more
think it's like,
"Oh, yeah, it's better
than my own currency.
"I'll take that any day."
So we'll see the jury's out.
I'm still ambivalent.
I think that it could
go either way right now.
If the U.S. government doesn't
step in and try to squash it
I think it could go much higher.
- Do you think despite
the opportunity
that we have right now
because of the chaos,
that just sort of generally
the Biden administration
with taxes and regulation
and all that stuff
is gonna scare a lot of people
from building the
right businesses?
- What I think is that
typically, a president
inherits what they got from
the administration before them.
So Biden will reap the
rewards of Trumpism
and that will probably last
for the first year or so,
maybe two, and then the
effects of Bidenism,
whatever that might be,
the liberal policies
will start to really
take hold more
in the second and third year
and even fourth
year of his term.
So I think this is really weird.
I think that administrations,
they either get
the credit or blame
for things that really probably
weren't much of their own doing.
And my biggest thing
is immigration.
I don't get it.
I just don't understand.
I don't understand.
There's no doubt the
immigration system is broken.
I have clients or
immigration lawyers
and so I really have
a very good insight
into immigration right
now, really good insight.
So I understand the
system is terrible,
it's broken and needs to change.
There's a lot of terrible
things happen to illegal aliens
that shouldn't be happening,
that you probably...
I couldn't believe it until
I actually saw it myself
that there are things that
it wasn't Trump's fault.
It's been happening
for a long time.
It had started under Obama,
got worse under Trump.
But let's say, everyone
can stay, it's insane.
It's pissing in the
eye of every person
that legally came here,
as much as forgiving
student loans
is pissing in the
eye of every person
who went to school borrow
money and paid it back.
There's moral hazard
here in this thing.
And so obviously the
intelligent person would say,
"If I'm gonna make no
consequence for sneaking in,
"everyone's gonna
come and sneak in.
"If I make no consequence for
not paying back student loans,
"no one's gonna pay
back their loans."
So there's a huge issue
with these things.
And I think that the common
theme that you and I agree on
is that about just
personal responsibility
for one's actions.
And I think that's almost the
underlying theme on the left
is like there's almost a lack
of personal responsibility
for one's actions and where
one is in life at this moment.
- Where does just common
sense fall into that
'cause it's interesting
when I listen to you
it's like I know you can go
deep on all the business stuff
and how to help people
succeed and all that
but you just strike
me actually more
as just like a common sense guy
more than anything in a way.
That may be a Long Island
thing to at some level
or like a Queen's thing.
- I think common sense
is much more easily shown
when one isn't saddled
with prejudices.
(chuckles)
I don't care about any of the
social stuff on either side.
I just don't.
To me, I think people should
just do and be what they want
and have like...
I think a lot of the problems
with these both parties
is they represent
things that are so...
They're not...
There's politics and
there's other things.
I'm trying to say.
For me I think I see
things really clearly
because I don't care.
I always say I'm prejudiced
against two types of people,
lazy people and stupid people.
Other than that I love I
hate everybody else equally.
I think there
still is out there.
There's a lot of prejudice.
People have a lot of...
They come into an
idea not looking at it
from a level playing field.
And I think one thing
I do pretty well
is I'm able to take a step back
and go like it's all
going better on my own.
I just take a step back and say,
"Okay in truth in all
things being equal,
"let's take the bullshit
out of this thing,
"what's the real truth here?"
Yeah, I think I have
a pretty decent read.
I guess everyone probably
(laughing) thinks that.
No, I really think I
have a pretty good read.
I'm well educated,
I make sure I listen to a lot
of different points of view.
So I think that if
I sound reasonable
it's 'cause I'm not
allowing a belief I have,
a core belief I have,
whether it's about abortion
or being gay or this...
To me it's so stupid to allow
that to color your judgment
for other decisions,
but it does.
I think it does all the time
and it's really destructive to
the country and to the world.
I really think it is.
- How much of that do
you think is connected?
You just mentioned that
you believe in God?
I've been saying for
the last couple months,
that I'm probably
more of a believer now
than at any time in my
adult life for sure.
And I think it's partly that
I've watched so many people
from a purely secular
perspective or an
atheist perspective,
that just like they can change
their opinions on anything
on any given day,
depending on who said what,
or if Trump said something
you say the opposite,
something like that,
where were people
that have some belief,
we can all argue what
that definition of God is,
it just keeps you at
least some level centered.
- I think that...
I don't look at it like it's a
big man in the sky in a chair
like Abraham Lincoln
sitting against God.
I think there's like...
I don't think there's like...
I think that there's like...
I think that when you
really come down to it,
like God and science
is all very close.
Like, I think they're all like
two sides of the same coin.
Some people call it one thing,
others called something else.
But I just think
that I'm not the highest
authority out there myself.
I think there's someone...
I think that there is truth.
I think there is truth.
I think there's goodness,
and his badness,
there's right, there's wrong.
I think it's pretty obvious.
And I think those
things are just...
Where they come
from, I don't know.
When I say believe in God,
I mean, I believe there's
something out there
greater than myself and I
don't really care what it is.
I think it gets corrupted by
religion by organized religion.
I mean, that's the biggest
problem is that people...
It's such a powerful...
It's such a powerful pretense
and a powerful thought
and just a premise that
it's so easily corrupted
by smart people
for their own ends.
And I think religion
in organized sense,
is just that to the extreme
people that was smart
took some people, whether
it was Jesus or Buddha,
or whoever it might
be, or Mohammed,
had really amazing ideas,
whatever they were,
they were a higher level of
thinker or teacher or spirit.
And then ooh, I
could take that shit
and fricking make it good.
You know, damn, I can get
everyone to get money,
I can control the
population make them.
And that's probably
the worst view it.
I'm sure there's a lot
of benevolent people
in there as well but I
think that at some point,
a lot of this stuff goes
towards the darker side,
because it's so powerful
'cause it's such a...
Like I think one of the greatest
movies is like "Contact".
It's with Jodie Foster.
It's just a great movie.
- I love that Carl Sagan.
Right, it's a great
book, great movie.
And they ask that, "So you
think that 95% of the population
"is suffering from
mass delusion?"
(laughs)
- And she says, I've
asked the question.
- Basically I've answered
the question, right?
I think I've already
answered that question.
But the point is it's
a valid Occam's razor.
Again, like everyone...
It can all be crazy.
So, I think that...
My biggest fear right now...
You wanna know my
biggest fear Dave,
I'll tell you what it is.
My biggest fear is that
we're living in the midst
of a reordering of the world
as it is in terms of power
between China and
the United States.
And I think the moment the
big Cataclysm is gonna be,
if there is a shift away
from the U.S. dollar
to another currency,
whether it's the WAN
or some other currency,
this is going to be
that black swan moment
that the the reason the U.S.
is allowed to get away with
what they're allowed
to get away with
and reason the world
is typically stable
is the U.S. is that
stable currency,
it's backed by only one
thing, military might.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- That's all it is.
It's 'cause we have more
atom bombs and smart bombs
and planes and stealth
and this and that,
that at the end of the
day it just comes down
to we could blow you up.
Like it really comes
down to just that.
- Right because they
own all of our debt.
So it's like if they
call in the chips,
it's like if the mafia
doesn't have a guy
that can beat your guy up,
you're in pretty good shape.
- Exactly. It's really
sad, but it's true.
At the end of the day,
it really comes back...
Society is organized
around war powers.
It's about war protecting
and go back to ancient times.
So I think right now
is you have China
playing this really slow,
methodical long game.
Listen, you can't be a consumer
and stay on top for ever.
There's producers
and there's consumers
and the U.S. has become
a consumer based economy.
We make very little now
except ones and zeros.
And you know, China now is...
And by the way,
China is also getting
to the point now
where they are now...
As you start to elevate
out of that middle class,
you become more of a
consumer oriented country,
or a financial
services based country.
But that can't.
Watch what happens, though.
Look, where does the wealth go?
Where did the reserves go?
They flow always to the
people who are producing,
not consuming,
and that's why the U.S. is
basically flat broke right now.
And it's almost like...
We talk about too big
to fail with our banks
but the U.S. is the ultimate
example of too big to fail,
because the U.S. dollar
fails, well, good luck.
What happens next?
Not everything, but that's
the question is like
how long can you kick
the can down the road?
And I think there's probably
smarter people than me,
economics that really
studied this stuff.
Then may be no, I don't
really know, at this point
but it seems to me that at
a certain point in time,
something's gotta give,
and it's probably
gonna have to do
with an event,
whether it's an EMT...
- EMP I think you mean.
- Unless it's an EMP event,
something's gonna happen
that is gonna be impossible
to come back from
and that's when we're gonna see
a complete reordering
of everything.
And here's the thing,
how hard would that
be to happen, an EMP?
I always wonder like when is
one of these crazy rogue...
Let's reset the board.
Let's reset right board.
They all do a reset.
- They did it--
They did it in Ocean's 12
or was that Ocean's 11?
Maybe it was the
first one.(laughs)
- They did it in
Avengers and Civil War.
They did it in Sokovia,
(laughing) evil guy from
Sokovia did it right?
Exactly--
- If they've done it--
If they tell it in Avengers,
then clearly they do.
But I actually...
The broader point, though,
that they own so
much of our debt,
and that we owe
them so much money,
and that what ultimately keeps
us safe is just our military.
So it's like yeah, we
end up just kicking
everything down the
road until this...
It's almost like it
has to end horribly.
It's not really something
you want to think about.
But at some point, it's
like how does it not end?
It's not like we can
ever really pay them back
we can't get out of debt.
- Yeah.
- I'll tell you how it ends.
Very simple. Look at England.
Look at England.
I mean, England's a perfect
example of a post global power
that's a declining power,
that's basically...
It's not like...
If you look...
I just watched a
show called Bridget.
Did you see Bridget, it's
pretty good actually--
- I did, I know.
I know a bunch of
people who told me yeah.
- But you look back
at that wealth,
the concentrated
wealth and power
that this small island had.
They ruled the world by, you
know it's always about...
And what really killed Britain
was the the cost of
projecting their power
to the periphery, the Empire
was just too great to hold.
U.S. is in the same
situation right now.
And it always comes down to
how much does it cost you
to project your power out?
And I think that you
look at Britain right now
and what do you see?
Well, you still see a
big financial center
there in London,
you still see lots
of wealthy people.
But is a lot of
middle class luxury
that people would not have...
Feeling as a way out a
lot of just like a very...
Just that boom, it's not that
people were on the way up.
So I don't think it's
like the United States
becomes the great Dustbowl of...
Unless something really...
If it's a black swan
event, that's one thing
when something
really bad happens.
But I mean, a slow like
a decline I could see
could be U.S. just
becomes like...
There's always gonna be...
Listen, you drop me
my belief at least
you drop me into
the Sahara Desert,
and I will figure out a way
to become rich in
the Sahara Desert.
There's always gonna
be wealthy people
and entrepreneurs in the...
One thing the U.S. has this
entrepreneurial spirit ingenuity
so you'll always have
successful people.
What happens is the middle
class gets squeezed.
And it gets harder people
have to work harder
that the less the lower
class just struggles more.
And you have the...
And also what you have
with globalism too,
is a concentration of wealth
in the hands of a few people.
That's what you see with
the Bezos of the world.
I don't put Elon Musk
into that category at all.
I love you.
I think Elon Musk
is just like...
He's just got the
Elon Musk cool, dude,
net worth thing going on.
He's not monopolizing anything
at all, but he just like...
It's hysterical.
But other than Elon you look
at these guys that have...
Like Bezos and Facebook.
These are globalist people
that have made
money on globalism.
And because that's what...
Globalism concentrates wealth
in the few people's hands.
That's my opinion,
and it's very bad for most
people other than them.
- Did you see this thing
just in the last couple
of weeks that Bill Gates
is now the largest farm
owner in the United States.
Yeah, isn't that crazy?
It's like what does he
know that that we don't?
Or maybe we do know it,
we just can't afford it.
- Bill Gates has
always very quietly
been in things
like food security,
water security,
that's been a big
play for Bill Gates
quietly for many, many years.
So that didn't surprise
me when I saw that.
He's always been talking
about that stuff.
It's just that he's
been overshadowed in
the last few years
about his vaccinations
and stuff like that.
But, listen, there's two
sides size it to Bill Gates,
either he's a really benevolent,
amazing, brilliant genius,
or he is the most
evil man in the world.
It's like I kind of like...
Either I don't know.
If Bill Gates heart is
pure, I'ma say that,
"What a great guy he really is.
"What a wonderful guy."
Or he's frickin' Dr.--
- But if he ain't...
- Or he's Dr. Evil like you
know, I don't know, I mean,
I guess the jury's out.
I kind of like...
My ex wife really hates him.
She thinks he's real...
And like I always have,
I don't know, I think,
"What is he really done that's
so bad like I don't know?
"But like honestly you
don't know, you don't know,
"you don't know.
"Maybe she's right,
I don't know."
Like I don't know.
But it's certainly...
He's not gonna end
up going down history
as a guy who is like
interesting at all.
This guy. he's gonna be like,
"What an amazing,
benevolent, amazing guy,
"oh like Dr. frickin'
evil," you know?
- Yeah, this goes
one of two ways.
I have to back up for a second
'cause I don't have
any great drug stories
like being on Quaaludes
and having to drag
myself down the stairs
into the Lamborghini
or anything like that.
But the one good
drug story I have
is that in 1997, in the summer,
I ate a bunch of pot
brownies with some friends
and we went to the
movie theater, we're
basically tripping.
We were just like truly, when
it got you at that level,
like out of our mind.
We were going to see Air
Force One on opening night
and it was sold out.
The only other movie
we could go into,
you'll see why I'm telling
you this story was Contact,
which I had not heard of
Contact and I sat down
and I'm tripping, I mean,
I'm full on losing my shit
and that opening panorama
scene of the universe
that I'm sure you know, that
two minute just extended
and that thing blew my mind.
And it truly, it
changed my life.
I read all of Carl
Sagan's books after that.
Contact was his only nonfiction,
but I read all of his books,
and it changed my life,
it opened me to
all of that stuff.
I thought you would
appreciate that.
I know, it's not as exciting
as some of your drug adventures.
- A good pot brownie
story is always good
'cause like it's one
of those weird things
that you don't...
Like, "Uh-oh, I think
I ate too much."
- Uh-oh yeah. (laughs)
- It's an uh-oh moment,
and you can't shut it off.
You're like, "Oh my God!"
You know, we've all
had those.(laughs)
- Yeah.
What's next for you
with all this in mind,
all this opportunity and
all the stuff you're doing?
- I'm feeling like that I'm
really on path right now.
I think I kind of
love what I'm doing.
I love my the business
that I'm in right now.
And I'm slowly
but surely just...
What I'm doing is I'm
building a network really,
for recruiting and
going city by city
and ultimately then state
by state, country by country
and really trying
to create a platform
that will allow anybody
who wants to go into sales
to really easily get
themselves trained
and get a high paying job
and also allow companies
that are looking
for salespeople,
quality salespeople to
be able to go somewhere
and use this as a resource
to instantly be able
to find the type
of people they want
to know what their
level of training is,
how they perform on certain
types of tests and scores.
And I think this doesn't
exist right now, with sales
'cause for most professions,
you could look at
someone's resume
or their career or
their school and say,
"Oh, this person went
to Harvard or Yale,
"or this place or that place.
"And they've got this degree.
"So they've done the work."
And that doesn't hold up
when it comes to sales.
Like some of the worst
salespeople in the world
went to the best
schools and vice versa,
people that did not even
graduate high school
are incredible salespeople
and huge assets to companies.
So there's a
different parameter.
So I think it's a
very disjointed kind
of screwed up model
that how companies go
about choosing salespeople
and trying to scale
and it's probably the
biggest pain point.
So a company that's
trying to grow,
they'll typically say the
biggest pain points is...
My turnover of
salespeople was massive.
First Year attrition
is enormous.
First Year performance
is terrible.
So I'm trying to
address that problem
by really creating a much more
robust database and data set
for people to go out there
and choose salespeople.
So it's a long term
project I have right now.
It's like mapping the
genome of... (laughs)
No, it's shorter than that.
But I'm doing that right
now, it's going amazing.
And I'm doing a lot
of consulting right
now for companies,
exciting stuff and
I'm waiting anxiously
for the world to open.
And there's gonna be a just
a wonderful year for me
of just going country to
country to country to country
for all of those countries
that I always go to.
I just can have a fun
couple a year as well,
get to really travel
and do what I love doing
which is getting in
front of large crowds.
So in the mean time,
I'm just doing that
and having a lot of fun.
- Jordan, I owe you dinner.
We're doing it at
my place next week.
I'm gonna text you in a minute,
we'll get it on the books.
- Text me and well do it.
- And it was great
talking to you.
Wait are we sending...
Where are we sending people?
I wanna put
a link and the description--
- Jordanbelfort.com
or straightlinehiring.com.
Check it out and everyone
knows where to find me.
I'm a weed, I'm everywhere.
(laughs)
- Alright, good seeing you man.
- Take care, pal, bye.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about lifestyles
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our lifestyle playlist
and if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out our full episode playlist.
They're both right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.